the first season was what am i the
second season was where am i and I think
the third season is Who am I again
the real gods are coming there very
angry its season one was about the maze
in season two was about the door
what is season 3 about the world the
real world in season three is about
destiny free will and choice and data if
you from data I think it's about destiny
I think it's about whether or not we
control our own yeah I think it's about
Evans said the exact same thing which is
very curious for fans right now yeah
yeah it's all curious oh my god season
one's about the maze seasons who's about
the door I would say season three is
about the floor your jaw is gonna be on
it oh wow
maybe oh snap yeah that's very good yes
exactly because your jaw will be on it
yes this is a standard issue No
[Music]
you are the first the season 3 premiere
is so amazing and I know you directed it
as you guys were approaching especially
this first episode what was your goal
for Westworld for the fans out there
it's funny you know we sort of pitched
it this season right at the end of the
pitch for the pilot back in the day so
we always knew that we were going to get
here we're always incredibly excited
having built the the original world of
the show but a chance here with the same
amazing cast the same amazing crew to
kind of completely reinvent the show
around our idea of what we think the
future is going to look like so very
very excited with the challenge of that
I think he was just excited to
experiment with the future horse which
is this motorcycle yeah a lot of time he
spent researching and playing every
season is rooted in the perspective of
the host the first season
dolorous didn't even understand that she
was reliving her memories and completing
them with the president the second
season were much taking Bernards
perspective and he's trying to
reassemble a fractured mind the third
season follows several characters but
amongst them Darren paul's character
caleb and he understands the world that
he's in consequently we understand it if
you look at the timelines of the show
I'm sort of Cascade in this season into
the present in a moment in which
everyone is is in the present we
probably want to stay there for very
long season two was amazing but a little
difficult to understand at times do you
feel like season 3 is gonna be easier
for the fans to follow absolutely we
were never done telling our story season
2 and I think season two's job was to
set up a lot of things for this season
and now if there was anything confusing
or sort of up in the air I think it
falls into place quite nicely in season
3 it's a lot more linear you know we're
supposed to be experiencing things like
the hosts are and the first season was
what am I in the second season was where
am i and I think the third season is Who
am I
why are you Dolores you and I are a lot
alike they put you in a cage decided
what your life would be I did the same
thing to me
[Music]